hi my name is e2 Lou and I work
front-end graphics so today's talk I'm
going to talk about some new features
new updates about the graphics language
so my name is Lu Chu Lu I work on
front-end graphics so today I'm going to
talk about some updates about the
graphics language first I'm going to
talk about some of the new features and
optimizations well come with virtually
eleven note version 12 sorry and and
also after that I'm going to talk a
little bit more beyond the twelve the
first is the local greatest complex so
before we have the graphics complex and
you can specify the complex coordinates
and the in that's specified in the
primitive okay sorry but now for some
cases it's not very convenient therefore
the necessary barkis's now we have the
syntax to put them together in the same
primitive box have the complex and then
have the index these two should be
behave exact same looks very very
straightforward and here comes the
options so for the currently the options
go with graphics complex but with a new
syntax you can specify with the
primitive directly and this syntax will
be supported by most 2d and 3d
primitives in version 12 next polygon
was host this has been requested many
years in different forms but now we have
something it is available as the new
syntax as a polygon so you can define
the boundary of the polygon and together
is it you can associate it with a bunch
of host multiple of them and
specify with the local graphics complex
we as well
these are 2d or 3d exam and yeah so you
can try to edit and put notice that that
overlap at all overlap part where I just
work as it should be
this is 3d case so for options we supply
two ways why is it automatic the other
one is explicitly when for the automatic
case it allows user to like exactly like
a paper cut and the Union you don't need
to worry about the attribute inside and
other the other way is you can specify
explicitly and it will be respected I
can see some difference there and the
reader will walk with both texture and
vertex colors and the first video work
we work with the vertex normals as well
here a bunch more examples slightly more
complicated that the boundary can be
concave the hole itself can be concave
as well let's try to so was it mercy the
the part get the the educated cutter
will not show up
and yeah and if if there's something go
over this part will be not not be sure
up
we're not show up as well and here's a
another example with slightly more
complicated polygons the polygon itself
is intersecting with each other with its
himself and and the part that the hole
itself are stars as well it it works
with itself with different options so
bunnies fear previously we always have
the concept of bounding box but for some
cases people don't specify the box and
the axis stuff we probably you you need
a bunny sphere concept you can specify
that with the spherical region and with
user coordinates if it is specified the
view center and the view angle will be
preceded but it is a it is good at you
don't need to struggle to figure out
what is the right of your angle here's
the examples can the videos this is 1
this is 3 and this is another example
with a not to me plot 3d this is a the
model for the for the whole human being
and you can just choose to visualize the
the part you want so we have several
optimizations and the new options with
Reza 3d the first one is is is mean
sample so sometimes you have very low
resolution voxel data and the data will
ended up very blurry result like this
so now we add the feather this option
you can control - - can do that what it
does is it while we sampled your input
data - at least this minimal size so you
can see if you improve ah this this side
this side will get much sharper and we
also did some uh plant optimizations a
combining raster sweetie and other
transparent graphic sweetie before it
was slow now it should be if there's no
overlap it will be just as fast as the
single rest of 3d transparency so
transparency is expensive and we are
amongst those very few companies where
Trudy this very very seriously we try to
make all the transparent polygons render
correctly and in history we use the BSP
tree which is a splitting or polygons
into tiny pieces so then that you can
sort them consumes a lot of memory and
time as well and then will come with the
multiple would sing mat will pass step
spilling we don't need to sort but you
probably you need to arrange multiple
times because each time it only pure
wrong layer off now with the hardware's
and the newer technology which which is
open geo 4.2 we are able to do single
pass steps peeling so you just need to
random once and the orchid order layers
here are some data are collected on my
four-year-old laptop and you can see
compared to multiple past depth peeling
the think of has that feeling will be
slightly four to five times faster this
is like several million polygons Maru
and why we are adding new features we
are also trying to optimize polygons
both a memory side and the performance
side and here are examples I were trying
to provide a different plot points the
points can choose the sample points in
both X direction in the Y direction so
if rather see examples in version 9 my
laptop windows 64-bit with 16 ran it can
only reach like 1500 and after a long
waiting
it is not very responding with 10-4 we
did some rewriting of the low-level code
and they're random more polygons and the
performance improves a lot I will keep
improved in 11 3 and the version 12 we
we also we we also keep up optimizing
the the memory cider so compared to
version 9 it's it's a run three times
more polygons it's both x and y
direction so surface parent surface
pairs as is directive which allows you
to do a lot of low-level shading
language stuff what you can do with it
is you can customize your own rendering
with the shadows the walkways both 2d
and 3d and the works other all platforms
currently follow the gr salon 1.2
standard and now it takes the
association syntax and the it would be
more straightforward more readable so
here's a name it you beauty is something
attribute do you want to get from
primitive like the positioning and and
vertex normal vertical
and the vertex texture coordinates and
the parameter is something you can
provide yourself defining yourself you
can call it directly in the shadow
you can also incur this from some of our
building a directive and options as well
and more important there you need to
specify the shadow program for both
fragment and the vertex so these seems
very low level gives you a lot of
flexibility so what do you can what can
you do with it our show two examples
shadow is currently the future we don't
have in our graphics language we were
see how we can do in surface appearance
to achieve that Shadow Man mapping it's
a two pass rendering method the first
pass we are you are get a depth map from
the light source I and then at the
second pass rounding you use that depth
map compared to decide which area is
shaded which is not because the depth
map is shows only the closest object
depth so to do that you probably need to
define a bunch of matrix two converter
you'd use a cornice into like a Ferguson
lighting source space and we add a
definite definition the first wise is is
the first path to generate the depth map
and this is a second pass and it will
have some lighting Computing's
i simplify that to use that simple
simple directional and point lighting
and it is totally customized and now you
need to define the two path graphics
first path generated the the the depth
map are using surface parents which is
different defined previously
they're also the shedded of graphics 3d
which is does everything since its to
pass messages the first pass result and
you need to be passing texture and they
use it in the second pass so now let's
just give it some some polygons to see
how how it works
so this is something object the lighting
sauce coming from here you'll see it
works as expected it and this is the the
depth map generated from the first a
random path now we you just defined
customize the graphics 3d and just
feeding some some data and you see how
that works we just take some data for
example data and the you you you also
need to feed in the plot range as well
so so so you'll see this in this example
you are see the two shaded area this is
the shadow of this part and the shadow
from this part and let's try with
different data set and see how that
works they will have different plot
range and they have different data size
it should you should work with all of
them and the area and let's try a little
more complicated model which is how it
will take to the three seconds oh yeah
it's Donna so you are see this shadow of
the air
over here and other paths as well so
which means yeah you just make your own
customized renderer and here's another
example in the bump mapping which is we
don't have you know our graphics
language it either and that's trying to
to see how can we do it with it so did
you you need to define your lighting
model as well this is little more
slightly more complicated it because is
this a exactly the shadow used there the
lighting model used in front end it
handles all the lighting options and
also like different cornice like scatter
cornice and their user cornets so you
can use them in your defined function so
defining the box and give the texture
that the normal map has a texture and
you will get something like this let's
try to see please see the the
highlighted part the specularity you can
see a lot of tabs perceptions and there
and a lot of details there
and this is d for the lighting and let's
try a different lighting point lighting
so so take a look at this part it's you
can see it's really a lot of details
there because each pixel has its own
normal you don't have to construct a
very complicated models for that and you
just need to provide it in a normal map
and it's very fast so this is another
thing you can do with surface appearance
now I'm going to talk about some some
new features who are beyond at version
12 we are having good progress with
direct3d 11 and meta which are new api's
which allows a success a bunch of new
features both Windows and Mac among them
the one of the things that it allows you
choose different hardware's
for example currently computers will
have integrated have dis created
hardware and sometimes you might have
external one you can choose between them
and they through the prefer the GPU
option it will work with both Windows
and Mac and the seasoning information we
also show more information so you are
listed all the informations about the
different different hardware so you can
compare them and choose between them and
also listen to the one currently work
with Mathematica building studio and
this has been requested there as well
and it now works with direct3d 11 and we
are doing the same thing we are doing it
in the same way as unity does this on
Windows so as long as your hardware work
with unity are in the stereo part it
should work with us as well
and it will work with any 3d graphics
including the volume rendering the rest
of 3d
and a video desktop hardware test data
there are their work but then a mobile
one we are not that's a requirement and
other than that we probably won't get a
better text and tickle labels who are
getting much sharper text on windows in
graphics 3d and first tab spilling will
also be supported on posts of the new AP
eyes and they might be born they are
being they might be more features coming
as well so that's that's about it
so do you have any questions